Hello! Hello!
We are the Royal Institution.
We create videos that make you
think deeply about science
and the world around you.
And we need your help!
We’ve been engaging people with
the world of science for over 200 years,
and have a history packed full of
scientific discoveries
and incredible people.
Today, we carry on that fine tradition
at our home in London
and here on YouTube with you.
Our thought provoking lectures,
explosive demos,
and beautifully crafted animations
will always be free,
for everyone to watch.
But making videos is expensive.
Despite our rather grand name
we are just a regular old charity,
which means we rely on donations
and money we can make ourselves.
We bring in a little bit each
month through YouTube ads,
but it’s nowhere near
enough to cover our costs.
That’s where you come in.
If you value what we do,
please consider sending us a small
donation each month on Patreon.
Even just one pound or one dollar per month
will make a massive difference to us.
You’ll get some cool perks as a thank you.
But much more importantly,
you’ll get a warm fuzzy feeling
knowing you’re contributing
to something special.
The more money we can raise,
the more films we can make,
and the more science we
can share with the world.
Thank you!